[Music]
I'd like to apply for the position on
your construction site but you are aware
that you have to be strong to work in
construction I didn't know I'd have to
push the crane you know how it is you
would be the only woman on the
construction site that would make the
work right to a halt I can't risk that
[Music]
back in the old days it was clear that
work on construction site was men's work
it called from muscles and strength but
today machines have taken over a lot of
that physical labor and that has opened
the door for women to the previously
closed world of construction now we are
here and we're planning to stay
when engineer LAN is at I had told the
head of personnel at former company that
she was pregnant her response was
congratulations
say goodbye to your career today psychic
is responsible for 120 staff and she's
all for mixed gender teams on
construction sites
wooden c4 antique men respect you from
the start or did you have to prove
yourself Eisen in the ultras in this
sector women occupy only 10% of all
technical positions so it can sometimes
be a pretty rough place sometimes in
meetings I get mistaken for an intern or
an assistant then what I often I try to
turn it to my advantage in negotiations
for instance it can be embarrassing for
them they'll start off like hello are
you taking notes
no actually I'm the boss that's a moment
of shock for the man who said it and
that can help in the negotiations
what's good about mixed teams and women
in general on building sites as well as
avakov it's been shown by the Albright
foundation for instance that mixed teams
are more innovative and improve
workplace atmosphere but women in
construction are still pioneers because
there are so few of them the first women
out there like our site manager have to
show their teams I'm there for you you
can depend on me and I don't need
special treatment our client's want
quick solutions and this new willingness
to discuss with the group and respect
different perspectives helps to respect
you I see this women still not getting
hired on the lease of the bottle is a
special situation on construction sites
when we have mixed teams we need two
portable toilets one toilet is enough
for men but if a woman joins them you
need a second toilet and that costs
money not every company can afford two
facilities you can't charge the client
they don't care if there are women or
not there are things people often don't
consider but they make a difference do
women have to be more highly qualified
than men and to get a job it's like
Americans and loud women need to be
louder
we're often equally qualified or even
better qualified but we tend to sweep
that under the carpet and not trust
ourselves it amuses me in job interviews
when you ask a man what he's good at he
says
everything a woman says nothing special
that doesn't make sense
and Einstein so all of you girls and
women time to get your hard hats on and
stop thinking of construction as an
exclusive men's club start thinking
about what you'd like to build the
tallest building in the world the
longest bridge the fastest railway track
as long as it isn't a wall the world has
already enough of those
[Music]